a una muy buena victoria para el partido
demócrata para la fórmula a maiden
harris todavía hay que terminar el
escrutinio final y ver en qué con
cuántos electores terminan los
demócratas pero evidentemente en
especial con el estado de pensilvania
bardem llega es fuerte al número mágico
que necesitaba doscientos setenta
el escrutinio final de donde estaban las
boletas electorales en pensilvania
principalmente en ciudades
de fuerte electorado demócrata pareciera
ser que cualquiera de las estrategias
judiciales de la un presidente no por
mucho más
trump que quiere aplicar a pensilvania
que le va a ser muy difícil de contestar
esos esos resultados